you're looking at an unsinkable metal
watch it again even if you hold it down
it pops right back up this is not an
illusion researchers at the University
of Rochester made this metal object
buoyant by taking inspiration from
nature specifically from rafts of
floating fire ants the metal was etched
with a crazy powerful laser making it
super hydrophobic or extremely water
repellent even if you poke it with holes
it still rushes to the surface meaning
you could conceivably build unsinkable
ships with it to learn more about the
technology we sat down with one of its
inventors describe for us what you have
done in this new project this project is
actually a following of work we did a
number of years ago and at that time we
developed this so-called super
hydrophobic surface we use ultra-fast
laser pulses to process material surface
so the surface will consist of room gel
on micro structures and nano structures
they can trap a lot of air by the
surface structures so essentially we
have an air cushion right on top of the
surface so how do you then use these
super hydrophobic materials to create
something that's actually unsinkable so
we start with our super hydrophobic
surfaces we arrange them facing each
other and then there's a air gap in
between so this structure trap large
amount of air and then the whole thing
will have effective density less than
water so we have a very high buoyancy
you will keep floating back off and you
can even damage the structure you can
poke holes in it and it would still
float yeah absolutely the reason for
that is if you punctured the surface
it's only that part will will the water
will come in but the surrani area will
see
for me properly we'll still keep the
water off remaining sections and they
can still flow therefore he principle
given park as many holes as as you want
you can reduce this to zero and the
structural shoe and matter saying is
that you had some inspiration here from
nature one type is item down spiders the
other type is fire ends the common
feature is they both have some super
hydrophobic body surfaces for the spider
they need their entire life underneath
water but they still need to breathe air
so what they do is they periodically
come to the surface and then and then
use their hydrophobic body to grab some
air and then trapped air and underneath
the water they will breathe into this
water this air bubble so they can leap
underneath the water and for fire ends
so all the fire ants has also have this
survivor fully phobic body surfaces they
grab onto each other and form a raft and
this raft will keep them afloat because
the large amount of air trapped between
their body surfaces so is this thing
actually unsinkable this structure from
the extensive experiments we have done
is unsinkable
and as long as we keep this integrity of
this metallic structure and you will not
be able to push down of course you can
rip open the metallic structure the
super hydrophobic surface is simple and
you you can easily push down the super
hydrophobic surface we did experiments
we submerges versus submerge for two
months and as soon as you release the
load is drawn back up again you know we
we haven't had time to test it for you
know permanently yeah but based on all
the evidence everything 22 is it's
extremely hot can you walk us through
what kind of laser you used
to edge this medal and how it went about
creating this super hydrophobic service
the laser we use is the so-called sample
second laser and fan per second is a one
meaning of a building of a second
extremely short timers meeting this
short time berth the peak power of the
laser poles each extremely high is
actually equivalent to the wattage of
the entire North American power grid the
laser pulse just delivered is extremely
intense posts onto the surface and
instantaneously they can turn form a
smooth metal surface into a highly
textured one beyond the lab but this
little tiny piece of metal where might
it be applied in the future with the
large laser faster scanning speed we can
speed this up and really make it in the
much larger scale and a product or to
applications such as ships and ocean
vessels and also floatation devices for
the electronic protections one of those
electronic to deploy SC so you were to
scale this up into something like a
larger structure that you want to be
unsinkable could theoretically a really
heavy load weigh it down kind of as you
have done in the lab to make it actually
sink so the current ship they have this
structure they basically display a large
amount of water with the heavy load
right the problem is once the the ship
get damaged the structure itself will
not be afloat and that part and the ship
eventual will sink our structure we can
also make the ship whole with our
metallic assembly and we still can
benefit the same our loading capacity we
still can make the same shape but the
difference is if there's a damage the
metallic structure itself is able to
survive thank you for taking the time
thank you for for your interest in our
research